portion of this episode is sponsored by
google
[Music]
um
hello internet welcome to film theory
where i wish i had a shadow man feed me
when lights go off
what is this thing oh you're a horrific
monster
on second thought maybe not ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to the walton
files for those of you don't remember
the walton files is the analog horror
series from chilean creator martin walls
with a story that's gonna melt your
brain and a sound design that's gonna
melt your ears
apologies headphone users it's a story
about the now defunct bonds burgers an
animatronic themed restaurant chain
founded by business partners jack walton
and felix crankin through the first two
installments of the series we learned
that these two men had a falling out and
that bonds had been forced to close
shortly after its opening due to some
mysterious event called the incident of
1974.
honestly though it feels more accurate
to call this the incidents of 1974
considering that this is the year of
jack's disappearance his wife rosemary's
untimely death and stuffing into shaw
the sheep and another woman named susan
woodings winding up inside banny the
bunny i mean it was a busy year for the
franchise after the closure due to the
incidents of 1974 the animatronics were
relocated out into the woods where they
proceeded to take the lives of a few
more victims as they lay and wait for
the return of the mysterious character
named sophie a former caretaker of the
bonds burgers facility that we briefly
saw in the very first episode of the
series a person that the animatronics
are particularly keen on getting their
hands on as evidenced by them killing
brian stells because he quote looked
like her and as of last episode that's
where we left things off almost there
was one final video i hinted at towards
the end of that last episode by piecing
together flashes of a url left at the
beginning and end of the relocate
project upload we're brought to an
unlisted video titled lucky u where we
see wait what is this what is this it's
a clearly laid out timeline of events
i'm crying because i'm so happy also
watch the endoskeleton boogie down
if there was any lingering confusion
about the order of this story lucky you
is basically the teacher's answer key
and it confirms everything that we
talked about last upload however there's
still one major reveal here the return
of sophie you must be so confused about
what you saw don't be scared my little
bunny for i'm going to tell you a story
of broken people beautiful people safety
and pills sophie this now pretty much
marks sophie as our main character
remember the first thing that we hear in
episode 1 of the series is backwards
text that gives us this message you
finally start to remember that old day
they will look out for you soon this
whole story from its opening moments has
been an attempt to wake up long dormant
memories inside sophie's mind and now we
have a fuller picture of what's going on
sophie was once a caretaker of bond's
burgers she survives a tragic accident
or a bond attack something that would
cause her memories to be locked away
behind a gate of trauma and medication
so the question now is what exactly are
those memories that need to be unlocked
for that we finally turn to episode
three bunny farm the last canonical
installment in the series and the one
where we watch as sophie's memories come
flooding back the premise for this
hour-long upload is that sophie now aged
22 is playing through the old bunny
smiles incorporated arcade game bunny
farm along the way she's presented with
her family's tragic backstory forced to
face literal corpses to which she
responds
but that was very confusing
understatement of the year there soph as
she plays through the game she taps into
glitches and hidden files that provide
us with massive lore dumps these reveals
ultimately break down into three major
chunks the first is susan wooding's
audio log audio log number three it's
worth noting we've yet to hear numbers
one and two through this file we learned
that susan was the engineer for the
animatronics the one that essentially
built them when they're found
malfunctioning on opening day well
this happens
this tells us a few things first that
they begin to malfunction after jack's
disappearance but before anyone actually
gets stuffed two it confirms what we
suspected that she is in fact the one
inside of the banny suit and that she
doesn't appear to have any family
connection to the waltons themselves
interestingly based on this teeny tiny
text right here that's really tough to
read we see that she's still alive
inside of the suit somehow and that her
stomach feels weird which probably
connects back to the shadow man feeding
her when lights go off that we saw
happen in the relocate project and
finally susan's tape here brings up an
interesting loose thread susan says this
chris left some hours ago and felix
didn't even show up she mentions someone
named chris now earlier in bunny farm we
see that chris is the name for one of
the saved game files on the arcade
cabinet but the name actually comes up
even earlier than that the first time we
actually hear about chris is way back in
the first uploaded series where chris is
the one that ultimately sends brian
stells to the animatronic storage
facility and ultimately to his death
it's hard to hear exactly but chris's
name is definitely mentioned here anyway
so
chris told me this place hasn't been
working since about 78
79. so could chris be the identity of
our shadow man the one person who has a
connection to the franchise since its
earliest days and has survived to tell
the tale feeding the animatronics at
night it remains to be seen but chris is
definitely suspect number one the second
major chunk of this upload gives us the
identity of yet another animatronic this
time bouzou the ringmaster bunny farm is
very explicit in showing us that a man
named charles has been stuffed inside of
the suit and that he's been missing
since 7 14 missing
five days before the restaurants shut
down some scary breathing and jump
scares later we get this line a line
that's only visible via the closed
captions i don't remember my face chris
and now charles are two major loose
threads that we have coming out of this
upload we know that they're important to
the story but we don't quite know their
role in any of this last is the most
tragic chunk of the three which you know
is saying a lot considering that we just
went through two horrific murders
through a series of redacted diary
entries we learned how felix's marriage
to his wife linda falls apart and how
felix has increasingly turned towards
alcohol for some reason his problems
actually date back to 1964
10 years before any of the bonds burgers
drama started to kick up in fact they
don't start pitching the restaurant idea
until a year later in 1965 to a company
called cyber fun tech so it seems like
trouble was brewing in felix's life much
earlier than most walton file theorists
suspect but it all wouldn't fall apart
until a fateful phone call when jack
asks felix to take his two kids ed and
molly to their school dance
[Applause]
[Music]
jack would soon find out that felix
would not in fact be a lifesaver but
before we get to how you know what is a
lifesaver our sponsor for this portion
of today's episode google specifically
their password manager because sometimes
the scariest thing after you isn't a
possessed bunny animatronic looking to
stuff you into a robot suit sometimes
it's just people looking to get access
to your information online did you know
that october is cyber security awareness
month yeah i didn't either but
apparently it is and i call that out
just because online security is one of
those things that we all don't tend to
prioritize sure we lock our cars we lock
our houses maybe get security devices
and hide our keys to protect our
physical stuff but what are we really
doing to protect our digital stuff you
know the really important things like
access to our bank accounts billing
information the keys to our online
identities well the first two steps in
that process are one having strong
passwords for your accounts and two not
reusing those passwords statistically an
average person has over 27 separate
accounts to keep track of that is a lot
of information and if you reuse
passwords and one of those sites has a
data leak then all your information is
vulnerable as one website dominoes into
the next but if you use a different
password for each one boom the
vulnerability stops right there and look
i get it it's just easier if you have
one or two passwords that you rotate
between 75 percent of people get
frustrated trying to remember their
passwords and so 66 percent of people
tend to reuse them but that's an issue
the loyalists of theorists out there
will remember a few years ago when we
partnered with real life penetration
testers to get a sense of what being a
hacker is like in real life and through
those conversations we learned that
cyber security tends to boil down to one
thing the problem that we run into in
real world scenarios is that people
depend on convenience over security
people reuse passwords because it's
convenient even if it's not all that
safe but with google's password manager
you get both security and convenience as
google creates unique highly complex
passwords for each of your accounts
protects them using their advanced
security and then automatically fills
them back in when you need access and
because it's built into your google
account it has the added convenience of
making those passwords accessible across
any device anyway the reason i bring all
this up is that i trust google products
to keep me secure i mean my entire life
and the lives of all our employees this
entire business really just depends on
the security of these channels which are
literally accessed by a handful of
passwords and with google i feel
protected because not only are my
passwords kept under their strict lock
and key but google also notifies me each
and every time someone tries to access
my account or anytime they find one of
my passwords has become vulnerable it
allows me to stay secure without having
to constantly worry about staying secure
so if you're interested in learning more
about how google helps protect your
information online visit g.co
safer passwords easier option link is in
the top line of the description thank
you again to google for keeping me safe
for the last decade and for sponsoring
this part of the episode now back to the
fictional scary stuff as you might have
predicted felix with his alcohol issue
is not fit to drive that night via the
diary entries we learned that linda had
officially left him earlier that day may
2nd and after drinking more at the
school dance which guess things were
different at school dances back in the
70s he gets lost on the drive back home
and ultimately winds up in a horrific
car crash that kills both of jack's
children ed and molly terrified of what
he's done and what he could possibly
tell jack he buries the two kids as a
cover-up for his actions this in turn is
the memory that sophie needed to unlock
you must find sophie this is
this just got so much deeper than i
thought and now i think i
i know what's happening in the end we
clearly see ed and molly depicted as two
red children rise out of the ground and
possess their gray stuffed animal rocket
rabbits two children sharing one
character wait is is rocket just the
walton files equivalent of golden freddy
did everyone realize that golden freddy
actually had two spirits inside of one
suit before i did what are the dates of
this one walton files okay golden freddy
spirit theory uh-huh okay i i was ahead
of it
by a little bit and then bunny farm ends
on that uplifting note from here we get
one final check in with our happy little
animatronic family a final sequence of
jump scares and uh that's it a somber
ending to an intense three video ride of
horror and tragedy and honestly it's a
pretty tightly written episode in this
one extended upload we get a lot of the
answers that we were looking for last
time who is sophie why is she important
what she's supposed to remember check
check and check we know all those things
now but for everything that it
explicitly answers bunny farm still
leaves one of our biggest questions
open-ended the biggest being where's
jack his frantic phone calls to felix
the night of the crash asking about his
children are to date the last time we
actually see or hear from him sometime
in the next month after those calls he
disappears the robots start acting funny
the restaurant opens rosemary gets
stuffed into shaw and things quickly
close but whether that's jack getting
stuffed into bond jack stuffing himself
into bond william afton style or him
just literally disappearing out of grief
and despair in a quest to find some way
to bring his kids back it's unclear
after all someone caused the
animatronics to go haywire before
opening day of the restaurant could it
have been jack and his grief maybe the
evidence we have right now points to
jack being dead or stuffed into the bond
suit like you might expect in video one
we get a brief glimpse of jack's missing
poster which comes accompanied with a
message of let me out of here and
considering that susan in bunny farms
says that she's alive inside the bany
suit stuffed people in this universe
appear to be conscious inside of their
animatronic prisons for more proof of
jack's fate though look no further than
the actual farm in bunny farm you'll
notice that even though the game in
question is called bunny farm the farm
actually belongs to a character named
pete the hippo guess hippo farm doesn't
have the same ring to it anyway during
sophie's playthrough there's a lingered
on shot of a plaque describing the whole
area as being founded by a hippo named
bobby with two children johnny and pete
bobby who's now deceased year unknown
had promised to build the greatest barn
ever later this plaque changes to
instead reference the deaths of ed and
molly walton which by proxy would mean
that bobby our dead hippo is then the
stand-in for jack walton our dead or
stuffed protagonist connected to that
who or what is bon the animatronic money
it's easy to assume that bonn and jack
are one in the same if the bunny shaped
animatronic rabbit foot fits wear it you
know but i'm i'm just not convinced on
one hand the springtrap connection of a
morning father losing his mind and
trying to put the pieces of a broken
family back together is hard to deny on
the other though i just don't see jack a
loving father actively luring his loving
wife rosemary to her death in the guise
of bonn plus we get a few additional
visual clues as to what might really be
going on here throughout bunny farm we
get the merging and separating of ed and
molly as these two red child spirits we
of course see them preparing for their
school dance on the front steps of their
house and we see both of their faces
multiple times around rocket rabbit
making it crystal clear that they're
inside of that beloved toy but in a
weird couple of creative decisions we
also see them split out of bond multiple
times during the night of the dance we
see the bond player character wander
around the school before passing behind
a wall and suddenly on the other side we
see ed and molly appear to hunt for
their uncle and during the final jump
scares of the bunny farm video we see
bond glitching with overlays of two
child spirits one boy and one girl so is
bond responding to the presence of these
two lost children are they inside of him
his murderous intentions born out of
their collective rage again just like we
see with gold and freddy over in snaplan
was rocket just a glorified vessel to
carry him from one body to the next it's
really unclear right now lastly though i
want to talk about the identity of
charles is he a walton a crankin at this
point we have a clear idea of pretty
much everyone else in the story jack
rosemary sophie ed and molly are all one
family felix was a friend and partner
who ultimately separates from his wife
linda susan woodings was an animatronic
designer who just seems to be an
employee kind of hanging out but
everything about charles outside of his
name is still a big question mark
despite him being one of the main
focuses of bunny farm that said i think
i have an idea about his role in all
this and the solution doesn't come in
the form of secret unlisted videos or
backwards text it comes instead in the
form of martin walls other non-canon
animated specials mixed into the release
of the walton files as a pair of
animated holiday specials the christmas
special called boozooz ghost and the
halloween special entitled the
mysterious house both feature alternate
versions of our beloved mascot
characters both also start off as
seemingly normal old-time holiday
specials before becoming the corrupted
nightmare fuel that you'd associate with
this series to quickly summarize
mysterious house is about a pair of
trick-or-treaters who fall victim to a
group of serial killers disguised as
versions of bon sha philly and a bizarre
new character called tva buzu's ghosts
meanwhile is a surreal remix of a
christmas carol that puts buzu or ring
master in the role of the rich miser
ebenezer scrooge and features a death
scene where the censored face looks very
similar to the contortions on charles
that we see throughout bunny farm now
i'm not suggesting that martin walls is
lying about these being non-canon videos
or anything what i am saying though is
that they might be testing out ideas or
inspired by things that are canon to the
actual story and if that's the case
bouzou being both a ringmaster i.e the
head of a circus performance as well as
the stand-in for ebenezer scrooge
literature's most famous money-grubbing
boss seems to be an intentional choice
it implies that charles was in some way
a higher up a boss maybe even the man
supervising it all consider this as it's
common with a series there's one final
hidden url inside of bunny farm with a
piece at the top of the video and a
second at the end following that link
leads you to a video called guilty where
we watch the tragic downfall of felix
from an enthusiastic young boss with a
dream to a substance abuser lamenting
his actions and it's in this video that
we start to track the history of their
company jack and felix found bunny
smiles incorporated back in 1967 just
two guys with a strange shared dream of
bringing animatronic fun to the masses
but in 1972 they sell to a new company
cyber fun tech notice the logos and
disclaimers on the title cards for all
these videos felix even calls it out
it's crazy how far we've made it just
everything really the cyber fun tech
deal the bonds burgers project it's
incredible and this is a part of the
franchise's lore that's really yet to be
explored the need for jack and felix to
actively involve a third partner
possibly in the form of whoever actually
ran cyber fun technologies a third
partner who has monetary leverage to
demand favors from one or both men to
keep the business going in the direction
that he wanted this i suspect is charles
the mystery face that lives inside of
buzu hence that character being depicted
as both ringmaster among the robots and
as scrooge in his animated special it's
my belief that we're going to learn that
charles is ultimately responsible for
felix's mental collapse anyway with a
new teaser out for installment for we
may learn these answers sooner than
later but at the end of the day what i
love about the series is that it's a
story about human characters in a world
full of animatronics not a story about
animatronic characters in a world full
of humans what makes the walton file
such an intensely disturbing story is
that it's a family tragedy sure there's
certainly terrifying imagery and sound
design but it's just set dressing for
real people going through intensely
horrific situations life a lot of times
is scary enough that's all you need the
killer bunny robot that's just the
cherry on top but hey that's just a
theory a film theory
and cuts
[Applause]
[Music]
oh